the weather warnings were sufficiently
serious that the army were called in 40
personnel from four stops came from
Catterick to help protect the village of
Mipham Royden Kruger Dale where people
have barely had time to take in the
damage done by major flooding last
weekend
I've got half the company working on
here I think there's just a general
concern that they've got to get
themselves prepared for we don't know
how much water's gonna fall but probably
quite considerable amount in extra 24
hours 36 hours more than two hundred
properties flooded here last week when a
month's rainfall came down in just 12
hours sheer volume of rain that fell
took everyone here by surprise so this
time around no one's taking any chances
sandbags were being delivered to protect
homes already damaged by flood water
inside David Williams home the carpet
has had to come out from the lounge
window they can see where flood defenses
are being built but still not finished a
multi-million pound project which began
after devastating floods in 2015 in
somebody to try and protect us from this
happening and it's failed this stark
front page of the Yorkshire Post called
on the government to act the lack of
action is is going to cost lives it's
not just property that's at risk it's
people's lives and and I just call upon
government to demonstrate that they do
regard this as a national emergency and
the sooner the better the Environment
Agency except they do need to find new
ways to manage rivers and protect
we are concerned with the climate
emergency it's going to bring stormy a
wetter winters like the likes were
seeing at the moment and that's why the
Environment Agency has developed a new
strategy to look at what needs to be
done for that for the for the future a
storm Dennis moved in across the UK it's
brought heavy rain and dangerously
strong winds that he throw passengers
got a bumpy ride as planes struggled to
land many other flights were cancelled
across the country warnings remain in
place for severe weather and with rain
falling on already saturated ground more
flooding is expected Becky Johnson Sky
News West Yorkshire